the end of a night shift for Nikolai and
his fellow miners they spent six hours
every night down this vast Coal Mine in
machiaveka near the city of dunesque
I've been doing this job for 18 years
there's no difference between night and
day many were mobilized we should do our
duty if we all go the mining stops the
mine isn't the surf declared dunyatz
Republic and the call which dumbass
region
used to feel the Ukrainian steel
industry before 2014 when Russian
separatists took control of the area
now the majority of the coal deposits
are within territories annexed by Russia
we've been walking for ages it's a 500
meters deep Coal Mine 75 kilometers long
and we're heading towards where
everything is is being done now they're
calling us and we have to rush
these wagons carry coal from the mining
area to the cage and to the mountain
it's alcohol that we mine it is a
valuable quality that's used in steel
production firstly Coke is made out of
it and then metal is made it's in demand
it's an unhospitable place to walk with
minimum safety standards but for the men
walking here it's their entire life
their bread and butter
too noisy too deep for them to catch the
sound of shelf fire above
I've been working in mining for 31 years
it's very difficult to work here because
there is not enough manpower most of the
young men were mobilized we go back to
the city where our families wait for us
under artillery fire
we are patient we are Russian people we
have our own Russian Spirit we have to
endure to feed our families the boys are
fighting for Freedom there and we are
mining coal here that's why it is
necessary to raise donbass from its
knees that's how we live our education
is shovel and coal
the outcome of their effort is loaded
into wagons soon the call will be
exported to customers on the Russia's
Banner not so long ago it was Ukraine's